in this episode of bigquery spotlight
we're gonna dive deep into how to ask a
question or run a query in bigquery
running queries is one of the most
fundamental parts of discovering
insights from your data today's question
what is the best jersey number you
should choose in order to improve your
basketball game stay tuned and find out
[Music]
it's no surprise that big data has made
its way into the world of professional
sports teams at every level are starting
to gather process and analyze data so
that they can get the most of their
players and find a competitive edge in
the game so see how this would work
let's check out the NCAA basketball
public data set available in bigquery
the data set contains play-by-play data
for several years worth of games you can
get information like fouls free throws
scores player numbers timeouts basically
as much data as the pros have so let's
see if we can use this data for today's
question and determine which jersey
number is the best 3-point shooter if
you want to follow along click on the
link in the description below to set up
your own bigquery sandbox where you can
analyze data without needing a credit
card once you're in the bigquery sandbox
head over to the google cloud
marketplace by clicking on add data and
then explore datasets search for the
NCAA basketball and click to launch the
data set in the bigquery UI the NCAA
basketball data set has a number of
different tables clicking on the play by
play table you can first view the table
details which indicates that there are
over 4 million rows of events that's a
lot of basketball data check the table
schema and you'll see each column or
field of data that's available for each
of those events but first let's look at
what those events are you can start to
explore the data by clicking on the
preview tab to view a few rows of sample
data but to get a more comprehensive
list of all the event types the best way
to find out is to run a query click
query table and a blank query will
appear in the editor with the table
reference pre-populated before we write
our query it's important to note that
the language used to communicate with
bigquery is sequel or structured query
language sequel is also the standard
language for communicating with
relational databases bigquery is an SI
sequel compliant so experienced
practitioners will hit the ground
running don't worry if you're not sequel
savvy there are plenty of resources for
learning or
brushing up on your sequel skills just a
quick web search away so now let's copy
in a sequel query to explore the event
types the key command is sequel for
retrieving data is select which we'll
use to pull in a list of all of the
different event types and number of
occurrences from the play-by-play table
notice that the table reference is in
the format of the GCP project name then
dataset name then table name separated
by dots and clothes with backticks not
quotes will select all the event types
and group the results so that we can get
the count of each events once the sequel
query is written click on the green
checkmark on the right hand side of the
window to open the query validator a
green checkmark means the query is valid
and will show the estimated amount of
data that the query will process when
you run it if the query is invalid a red
exclamation point icon is displayed you
can click on it and get some guidance on
how to correct the problem click run and
bigquery gets to work after the query
execution is complete the query service
displays the results as a table in the
web UI you can see that the event type
column has both three point made and
three point miss events now we can write
a new query which selects the jersey
number for each play by play events and
then uses the event types column to
determine the three-point field goal
accuracy for each jersey number click
run and then a less than a second we
have the answer looks like number 45
sinks the highest percentage of their
three pointer attempts of course buying
a New Jersey doesn't make you a better
basketball player right
an important note we can see that the
table we queried has three gigabytes of
data but bigquery only read the columns
needed and therefore just processed 78
megabytes of data
well basketball enthusiasts out there
try out the NCAA data set for yourself
and ask questions to discover what you
might be able to do to up your game if
you want to learn more about bigquery
check out the rest of our playlist and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
on YouTube for other great content
look out for the next episode of
bigquery spotlight and remember stay
curious
[Music]